Hi! I’m Lendert. I am a scientist and I work at Wageningen University in the Netherlands.
On the website www.best4soil.eu go to the page "Database".
Read the explanation on this page and then scroll down
to choose one of the two databases.
If the database is not in your language you change this
by choosing the language in the top left corner.
But for the moment we continue in English.
The demonstration of the database uses the example in
the Best4Soil factsheet on crop rotation.
First, you choose the country.
Then you choose the soil type.
Then you add the name of your request.
Now you select the crops.
You do this if possible already in the right order.
There are three groups of crops: Field crops including black fallow
Green manure and cover crops,
and vegetables (including strawberry).
In "Crop selection" you can change the order of the crop sequence.
Now you select the nematode species you would like to add to your request.
Then you click on the "Create scheme" button.
A pdf-file will now show up.
Depending on your device and your brower, this happens directly
or you have to check your downloaded files.
On the scheme you can see the crops in the selected order
The nematode species  are displayed in the header,
and just below you will see the soil types.
The colour of a cell describes the damage caused by
a nematode species to a host plant
The symbol in a cell describes the host status of a
plant for a nematode species
The letters of a column describe for which soil type
the information is valid
You can change the order of the crops by clicking on the arrows left of the crops.
You can remove a crop from your request.
You can also add a crop (or fallow) a second time to your request.
Background information is available by clicking on a cell.
For example onion & Dytylenchus dipsaci
or onion & Paratrichodorus teres
or potato & Globodera spp.
or potato & Paratrichodorus teres.